de temps en temps en temps sur quelques
arrêts on sait qu'ils pourraient
décrocher s'en sortir je pense que c'est
sa dernière chance tu n'as pas de
nouvelles de ton père je suis plutôt
selon en ce moment je vais une vie
normale tu comprends tu ne peux pas le
faire tout seul
[Musique]
moi non
c'est toi
s'il vous plaît vous savez à qui est ce
chat bob qu'il n'est pas venu vers toi
pour rien pop
il m'a dit qu'il voulait que tu
l'appelles comme ça dans le passé j'ai
gâché toutes les opportunités qui
s'offraient à moi je ne veux pas finir
que tu t'en sors bien game you tu ne
dois pas aller trop vite ce n'est pas
bon pour toi je suis prêt
et j'aurais bob il veillera sur moi je
sors
tu veux le garder n'est ce pas à tour à
ce chat on
essayez le et des baumes et moi il m'a
montré comment pouvait être la vie de
l'autre côté tu aimerais revenir de mars
tout le monde mérite une seconde chance
heureusement pour moi j'ai eu des
compagnons de route en or qui m'ont aidé
à la saisir ne me regarde pas comme ça
[Musique]
d'aplats bob